if you have two points and we're
representing this by x1y1 so that just
means point number 1 and x2 y2 that
means point number 2 what we're doing is
we're actually taking like an average
we're adding the x-coordinates together
and dividing by 2 that gives us the
middle horizontally and we're adding the
y-coordinates and dividing by 2 and that
gives us the average or the middle
vertically and so if you find the middle
horizontally and vertically you're
getting that midpoint in between those
two points so what we're gonna do now is
we're gonna do a couple examples say we
have the two points 3 2 & 9 4 we want to
find the middle the point halfway in
between so it's just like an average
we're gonna say 3 plus 9 divided by 2
and 2 plus 4 divided by 2 okay just want
to be careful you had two XS together
and divide by 2 and add the Y's together
/ - you don't want to add these or these
you want to add X's and then the Y's
okay so we get 12 divided by 2 which is
6 6 divided by 2 which is 3 so 6 3 is
going to be your mid